c'est Johann le premier candidat qu'on
applaudit très
fort il y a du monde hein oui comment tu
les trouves les grandes personnes euh
pas bien B oui pas bien B oui ça c'est
ce que j'aime vous il vous trouve
moche tu aimes mieux les enfants oui
pourquoi qu'est-ce que tu reproches aux
grandes personnes bah je préfère mes
parents et puis les autres non
non
oui bah c'est son droit hein bah j'ai
bien le droit quand même hein
B bar bar m des petit
[Applaudissements]
éé toi qui est ami t enfants bar bar
amène-nous petits éas au pays des B tout
le monde est content b b c'est avec toi
qu'on veut
partir pour trouver le
saintjoséphire POM pour finir éteindre
pom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourreaventure